hey what's going on folks I want to
release another spoiler happy video for
you guys today I actually planned on
doing my episode 2 review of the plot
league but I just got on Twitter saw
some new release photos have came out
today so I definitely want to report on
these for you guys so you know exactly
what's going on and you're up to date as
game of thrones' film in season 7 now
most of these photos are taking place as
the Lannisters have just sacked
Highgarden and they're marching back to
King's Landing and in these photos
they're preparing to film this big
battle scene to where the Lannisters
actually go up against the Dothraki and
the unsullied so I think things are
going to get pretty interesting for
Jamie and brawn and in Lannisters next
season because apparently they're going
to be involved in both these big battles
and I think the first one is the
Lannisters actually conquer Highgarden
but I think that's going to be the
battle where Jamie goes up against the
Tarly so we no randyll Tarly is this
amazing commander so I expect the
Lannisters to take a significant loss in
that battle so as they're marching back
to King's Landing I expect their forces
to be diminished at least a little bit
and the Dothraki and the unsullied
they've been well rested right now so
they could put up a pretty good fight
against the Lannisters even though they
have a pretty big army we know that the
threatening and solid of these amazing
fighters so there is a chance that Jamie
could lose that battle and we know that
it's said in the lake that that's when
he runs into Daenerys in her dragons and
that's when he's nearly killed by one of
the Dragons but brawn saves him so if
that ends up coming true we could
actually see Jamie become a prisoner
again and be a prisoner of Daenerys this
time and she could take him back to her
cape and that's when we could see Jamie
and Tyrion reunite and hopefully now
this is all just speculation we don't
really know what's going to happen in
these battles but I'd actually love to
see Jamie meet up with Tyrion again and
hopefully Tyrion could talk some sense
into Jamie and get him to you know
basically lay down his sword because I
really don't want to see Jamie with
Cersei anymore I'd love to see Jamie and
Tyrion actually
malt and I I'd like to see Jamie to
continue on his story arc of you know
getting his Redemption and becoming his
good guy so I'd actually love for that
to see that happen but you know there's
really no photo proof of what's actually
going to happen during this battle
because they're really just preparing to
film they haven't really shot any scenes
of them actually fighting yet but
there's one big spoiler I wanted to
release in his video that I think you
guys are going to like because I know it
definitely made me very exciting and if
you look at this photo you can see Jamie
he's actually carrying a brand new sword
and if you look closely that's actually
what is well so the good news is Jaime
Lannister is back in possession of
another Valyrian steel sword which I
know that makes me very happy because I
wasn't sure if we'd ever see this sword
again I think the last time I actually
saw it was when Joffrey died and he had
a sword laying across his body and I was
afraid they were going to bury the sword
with him and we'd never see it again in
regardless how Jamie became back in
possession of this sword I really don't
care I'm just glad there's another
Valyrian steel sword back in the show
and back in a fight because we know when
season a comes and they're going to have
to fight the night's king we're going to
need as much Valyrian steel as we
possibly can get our hands on so now
that Jamie's back in possession of the
sword it puts it back into play and a
chance to be in the final war so I'm
happy to see that so I wanted you guys
to see this I want to get your comments
on it tell me what you think about this
or being back in a play what do you
think about Jamie being the one to carry
this sword again let me know what you
guys think about this stuff and I'll see
you during my next video thanks guys bye